First of all, data in Pandas is often contained
in a structure called a dataframe. A dataframe is
a two-dimensional labeled data structure with columns which can
be different types if necessary. For example types like string,
int, float, and Boolean. You can think of a
dataframe as being similar to an Excel spreadsheet. We'll
talk about making dataframes in a bit. For now,
here's what an example dataframe might look like. Using data
describing passengers on the Titanic, and whether or not
they survived the Titanic's tragic collision with an iceberg.
Note that there are numerous columns. Name, age, fare,
and survived? These columns have different data-types. There are also
some Not-a-Number entries which happen when we don't specify
a value. There are a bunch of cool things
we can do with this data frame. Let's jump
to the command line. Say that I had already loaded
this data into a data frame called DF. We can operate on specific
columns by calling on them as if they were keys in a dictionary. For
example, DFH and we can call on specific rows by calling a data frame objects
loc method, and passing the row index as an argument, for example, df.loc('a').